wie wählt man wissenschaftlich richtig
ganz einfach mal wäre die partei die
wissenschaftlich belegt fakten versteht
und in ihr wahlprogramm aufgenommen hat
und wenn wir überleben wollen dann
müssen wir müssen die staaten und damit
die regierung den klimawandel aufhalten
das ist das wichtigste wissenschaftliche
ziel im moment darüber ist sich die
klimaforschung mit riesiger mehrheit
einig mit mancher partei in
regierungsverantwortung ist das zu
erreichen mit anderen parteien wird es
dagegen
lebensgefährlich hier also die große
klicks um wahlempfehlung und auch die
ist wissenschaftlich fundiert klicks
umsatz im future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science jesus
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen eins vorab die afd
fällt hier schon mal direkt raus die
partei interessiert sich tatsächlich ein
dreck für um es mit ihren worten mal zu
sagen unsere schöne deutsche heimat wenn
es nach ihr ginge würde deutschland im
mega tempo durch dürren unwetter und
flutkatastrophen zerstört werden die afg
ist ein querdenker unter den parteien
und wie wir inzwischen gelernt haben hat
querdenken nur relativ wenig mit denken
zu tun in ihrem parteiprogramm geht es
nur um klimaschutz also unwählbar die
restlichen parteien dagegen haben alle
ohne ausnahme
das 1,5 grad ziel in ihrem
parteiprogramm als ziel aufgeführt doch
wenn man sich dann die routenplanung
dorthin ansieht dann verfehlen alle
parteien ohne ausnahme das ziel manche
sollte man nicht wählen wenn einem sein
leben lieb ist und bei manchen sollte
man dann bei der regierungsarbeit genau
auf die finger schauen disclaimer bevor
es irgendwelche missverständnisse gibt
deutschland hat sich wie alle nationen
im pariser klimaschutzabkommen
völkerrechtlich bindender zu
verpflichtet alles zu tun die
klimaerwärmung unter zwei grad zu halten
bzw
eine erderwärmung um 1,5 grad
anzustreben auch wenn deutschland nur zu
zwei prozent zum menschengemachten co2
ausstoß beiträgt der die klimaerwärmung
wissenschaftlich belegt verursacht bis
auf die usa und china 3 übrigens alle
ländern nur im einstelligen bereich dazu
bei wenn sich alle diese länder auf den
standpunkt stellen würden dass sie
nichts unternehmen müssten ja da wäre
die klimakatastrophe nicht aufzuhalten
jede partei die also ernsthaft die
zerstörung der erde zumindest für die
meisten tiere und pflanzenarten
inklusive der menschen aufhalten will
und uns auch völkerrechtlich nicht
isolieren will muss also effektiv den
co2 ausstoß auf null bringen und das ist
ein wirklich ehrgeiziges ziel mit
kompromissen kommt man hier nicht weit
sie bedeuten weltweit den tod von
millionen menschen deswegen müssen
verkehr das heizen von gebäuden und die
industrie sehr schnell klimaneutral
werden und das ist eigentlich eine sehr
gute nachricht für die wirtschaft denn
dafür wird eine menge geld benötigt und
das schafft wiederum arbeitsplätze
denn es müssen viele autos windräder
solarzellen wärmepumpen geothermie
kraftwerke und so weiter und sofort
gebaut und unterhalten werden wir hier
das gegenteil behauptet der hat nicht
richtig beim wirtschaftsstudium oder in
der schule aufgepasst vielen dank an die
kolleginnen der zeit die hier eine tolle
vorarbeit gemacht haben und die
entsprechenden studien zusammengetragen
haben wer also noch mehr detaillierte
informationen sucht sollte sich dort den
artikel zum thema genau durchlesen ich
habe ihn hier unterlief verlinkt ihr
findet ihn auch in der video
beschreibung und im ersten kommentar
sehr gut sind auch die analysen von
cornelia und volker quaschning in ihrem
podcast das ist eine gute frage mit
ihrem klima wahlprogramm check auch der
link ist hier unter mir in der video
beschreibung und im ersten angeboten
kommentar los gehts kohleausstieg das
verbrennen von kohle gas und öl ist mit
am klimaschädlichen kohle spielt dabei
in deutschland eine besonders große
rolle die wissenschaft empfiehlt hier
einen möglichst schnellen ausstieg bis
spätestens 2030 dieses datum nennen nur
die linke und die grünen in ihrem
wahlprogramm union und spd halten am
jahr 2038 fest wobei dieses datum sowie
so wackelt weil öl gas und kohle durch
co2 zertifikate immer teurer wird der
koloss stromkonzern rwe hat sich aber
wohl vorzeitig mit billig zertifikaten
eingedeckt und dass die
braunkohleverstromung im rheinland noch
lange zabel sein könnte wissenschaftlich
gesehen ist das unverantwortlich und wer
sich hier auf den kompromiss auch mit
umweltverbänden auf das jahr 2038 beruft
setzt das leben der menschheit aufs
spiel ich könnte das immer wieder
wiederholen das ist nämlich die konkrete
konsequenz wenn die politik nicht auf
die wissenschaft wird also hier volle
punktzahl für die grünen und die linke
keine punkte für den rest ich bin hier
in der bewertung erhard weil nur
konkrete ziele wirklich helfen
geschwurbel bedeutet hier lebensgefahr
erneuerbare energien nur wenn wir die
erneuerbaren energien ausbauen können
wir das ziel des kohle ausstiegs auch
überhaupt erreichen doch hier hapert ist
ziemlich die katastrophale politik der
alten bundesregierung hat zum
arbeitsplatzabbau im bereich der
windkraftanlagen geführt 40.000 jobs
gelten als verloren der kohleausstieg
wurde wegen 20.000 arbeitsplätzen auf
2038 verschoben was wollen die parteien
die jetzt zur wahl antreten die gute
nachricht alle parteien wollen
erneuerbare energien ausbauen mit
ausnahme der afd konkret werden
allerdings nur die grünen und die linke
volle punktzahl für beide für fdp spd
und cdu csu nur halben punktzahl für den
guten willen allerdings der wird nicht
reichen verkehr wir müssen dringend
weniger mobil sein und wir müssen das
klimaneutral sein mehr fahrradfahren
mehr öffentliche verkehrsmittel
elektromobilität und vor allem sehr
schnell auf verbrenner verzichten das
ist der weg sagt die wissenschaft
übrigens könnte kurzfristig ein
tempolimit für eine deutliche reduktion
des co2 aus dem verkehr sorgen und da
wir spät dran sind muss das jetzt
relativ schnell geschehen fdp und union
setzen sogar auf wasserstoff vorbei das
laut der wissenschaft ineffizient ist
und es noch keine infrastruktur gibt und
sie wegen der hohen kosten nur langsam
ausgebaut wird das gibt punktabzug die
fdp will die bahn sogar privatisieren
was den anreiz hier günstige angebote zu
schaffen erheblich senken dürfte da
würde ich mal sagen fdp 0 punkte konkret
werden hier nur spd grüne und linke die
ein tempolimit und die deutliche
förderung der elektromobilität in ihren
wahlprogrammen haben das gibt volle
punktzahl und die cdu/csu kriegt noch
einen treffpunkt für das bemühen und das
obwohl sie wie die fdp fliegen fördern
will das macht so gar keinen sinn heizen
obwohl der co2 ausstoß in den letzten
jahren im gebäudesektor kontinuierlich
gesunken ist im moment stecken wir fest
weil eben doch weiter vor allem mit gas
oder öl geheizt wird so werden wir halt
einfach nicht klimaneutral
die fdp ist da mal wieder ganz vorne mit
dabei mit 0 vorschlägen also gibt es
auch null punkte tatsächlich aktiv
werden wollen nur spd cdu/csu und linke
ohne allerdings allzu konkret zu werden
dafür gibt es einen halben punkt die
grünen waren hier fleißiger und haben
relativ genaue pläne zum beispiel für
zwei millionen wärmepumpen bis 2025 das
gibt einen vollen punkt
industrie die industrie hat einen
riesigen energiebedarf und er kann auch
nicht so einfach mit erneuerbaren
energien gestellt werden wasserstoff
wäre hier eine gute lösung treibt aber
die kosten in die höhe die betriebe wäre
nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig hier müsste
der staat eingreifen und diese
mehrkosten erstmal übernehmen und auch
hier hat die fdp mal wieder den
schlechtesten vorschlag der markt wird
schon regeln immerhin verweist die fdp
auf co2 zertifikate aber ohne hier
wirklich genau hinzuschauen und zu
regeln wird die bundesrepublik ihre
völkerrechtlichen verpflichtungen nie
und nimmer einhalten können laut dem diw
econ institute haben hier die grünen das
beste konzept dahinter dümpeln union
linke und spd volle punktzahl also für
die grünen halbe punkte für den rest und
natürlich wieder mal keinen punkt für
die fdp landwirtschaft hier müssen wir
dringend eingreifen das fängt schon mit
dem vermeintlichen randthema der moore
an sie sind ein effektiver co2 speicher
wurden aber in deutschland schon vor
jahrzehnten trockengelegt sie müssen
schnellstmöglich wieder vernässt werden
wogegen sich aber
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
von der cdu mit händen und füßen wehrt
die cdu csu nennt dann auch keine
konkreten ziele übrigens genauso wie die
spd und die linke auch die tierhaltung
muss dringend reduziert werden zum einen
weil tiere unmengen an pflanzen fressen
müssen damit sie das fleisch liefern
können was wir dann essen wird auf
diesen flächen pflanzen angebaut werden
die dann vom menschen direkt gegessen
würden das wäre viel effizienter dann
würde auch weniger stickstoffdünger
benötigt der auch dringend reduziert
werden muss letztlich kann sich die
menschheit über kurz oder lang
fleischkonsum in diesem riesigen masse
gar nicht mehr leisten die flächen
reichen dafür einfach nicht und tiere
produzieren unmengen an klimagasen
besonders methan und lachgas inzwischen
gibt es auch so viele und oft sogar
bessere ersatzprodukte aus gemüse die
auch noch besser schmecken und so
traurig es ist mal wieder null punkte
für die fdp die damit das prädikat
lebensgefährlich erhält um konkret
bleiben linke cdu csu und die spd gut
für jeweils einen halben punkt und nur
das wahlprogramm der grünen liefert mal
wieder konkrete ideen das ergibt einen
punkt und damit wären wir beim gesamt
ergebnis dieses wahl checks fdp wählen
ist lebensgefährlich sie kommt gerade
mal auf insgesamt
0,5 punkte
cdu/csu wählen ist ein wenig wie
russisch roulette wenn man glück hat ist
die kammer mit der kugel er mit 2,5 von
sechs möglichen punkten landet sie auf
dem vorletzten platz auch die spd gibt
mit einem halben punkt mehr kein gutes
bild ab sie kämpft sich damit auf den
dritten platz vor was aber wirklich
absolut unzureichend ist die linke
dagegen liegt immerhin mit 4,5 punkten
auf dem zweiten platz dass es
überraschend wer sie wählt muss aber
vielleicht die ein oder andere kröte aus
ihrem wahlprogramm schlucken was
natürlich für alle parteien gilt denn
nicht nur klimaschutz wird in den wall
programm thematisiert und so mancher
punkt macht dann eine partei trotz guter
klimaschutzziele für den einen oder für
die andere unwählbar allerdings ist der
klimaschutz überlebenswichtig für die
gesamte menschheit und sollte mit
sicherheit bei der entscheidung ein
großes gewicht haben und da schneiden
die grünen mit abstand am besten ab 6
von 6 punkten die grünen werden in ihrem
programm einfach am konkretesten und
berücksichtigen die erkenntnisse der
wissenschaft am besten sechs von sechs
punkten wer hier also auf nummer sicher
gehen will der sollte die grünen wehren
aus wissenschaftlicher sicht um hier
noch etwas realismus reinzubringen auch
bei den grünen ist nicht alles gold was
glänzt denn auch mit ihrem wahlprogramm
ist es fraglich ob sie das 1 grad ziel
erreichen können und deutschland 2045
wie angestrebt wirklich klimaneutral ist
aber immerhin haben sie einen weg
eingeschlagen der das überhaupt
ermöglicht die aller parteien liefern
hier einfach nicht oder zu wenig und das
geht in diesen zeiten einfach nicht alle
links zu den wahlprogramm studien zu dem
wahlprogramm und noch mehr findet ihr
natürlich in der video beschreibung aber
das allerwichtigste
auch das ist wissenschaft wer nicht
wählen geht unterstützt die extremen
parteien am politischen rand egal ob
rechts oder links also nehmt eure macht
als souverän dieses landes war denn das
sind wir wählen denn und bestimmt die
zukunft mit wählen gehen ist auch eine
verpflichtung wir sehen uns dann im
wahllokal bis dann bleib dran